[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the top 10 mistakes
the first Harry Potter film made that
the new HBO Max show configs when the
Philosopher's Stone movie came out in
2001 Harry Potter fans all of the world
flocked at theaters to see their
favorite boy wizard brought to life and
while the film truly was magical in its
day it made a fair amount of mistakes
when compared to the novel with so much
detail to cram into a two and a half
hour movie it's completely
understandable that certain aspects of
the book were unable to make it into the
film version of the Philosopher's Stone
but in addition to some of these
omissions there were also just other
well mistakes today I'll be taking you
through 10 of the most obvious mistakes
from the first Harry Potter film which I
believe the new reboot of the series can
fix 1. Harry's eye color Harry is
described in the Philosopher's Stone as
having his mother's bright green eyes a
detail which turned out to be actually
quite a big focal point throughout the
series due in large part to the fact
that Severus Snape loved Harry's mother
dearly and Harry's green eyes reminded
him of her so with so much description
of and focus on the color of Harry's
eyes it was rather surprising for fans
when the Philosopher's Stone introduced
Daniel Radcliffe a decidedly blue-eyed
boy as Harry Potter couldn't they have
given him green contacts or something
well as it turns out the filmmakers did
try to use colored contact lenses to
correct this mistake but unfortunately
the young actor was allergic to the
colored lenses and he was unable to wear
them without incredible discomfort in
any case fingers crossed this should be
an easy fix in the upcoming television
series 2. wrong snake at the zoo this
has got to be one of the most trivial
mistakes in the entire movie series but
a mistake it still is at the very
beginning of the Philosopher's Stone
when Harry joins the dursleys on
Dudley's birthday trip to the zoo the
boys pair into a giant snake display
this is the scene in which Dudley Harry
out of the way and Harry inadvertently
makes the display glass disappear with
his magic the snake escapes but not
before thanking Harry in parcel tongue
now in the films there's a small sign
beside the snake's display indicating
that it's a Burmese python a species
native to a large area of Southeast Asia
but in the books the snake is actually a
boa constrictor a species native to
South America as I said it's trivial but
it is a mistake 3. Quirrell and Harry's
initial meeting accompanied by Hagrid on
his way to Diagon Alley for the first
time ever Harry met a large number of
witches and wizards as they passed
through the Leaky cauldron Pub among
them was the nervous and eccentric
Professor quirinus quarrel in the movie
we saw quarrel effectively require upon
the very sight of Harry during their
first interaction as he withheld his
hand from shaking Harry's yet in the
book quarrel enthusiastically shook
Harry's hand like everyone else imagine
this Choice was made by the filmmakers
in order to highlight the fact that
later on in the lots of a stone quarrel
was unable to touch Harry's skin without
incredible pain but this was only after
Voldemort fully possessed him at this
earlier point in the story the dark lord
had yet to take up residence on the
backside of girl's head which means he
should have been able to touch Harry
which of course in the book he did 4.
Ron's personality if there is one
mistake that I'm still upset about from
the Harry Potter films it would have to
be the inaccurate way that Ron Weasley's
character was represented Ron's
personality was absolutely destroyed in
the movies with the young wizard being
essentially produced to a walking
punchline and while bookron was funny
and endearingly eager to prove himself
he was never overly goofy or foolish so
much of Ron's loyalty Wizarding Street
smarts and bravery were completely
omitted from the films and it resulted
in a version of the character that was
quite simply inaccurate in fact some of
his greatest lines and pieces of wisdom
regarding Wizarding culture were given
to Hermione or others in my opinion this
is a huge mistake that the show can fix
5. Manny's appearance played by Emma
Watson the movie version of Hermione was
never going to be quite as plain as the
books described however there were
certain aspects of Miss Granger's
physical appearance but the movies
didn't accurately portray but could have
for example in the novel Hermione is
described as having rather large front
teeth that is until they were eventually
shrunk down in the Goblet of Fire in the
films Emma had quite beautiful teeth
throughout the entire series which made
for a rather poor unveiling of her
Makeover at the trial was a tournament
starts in the fourth movie although that
whole concept is a little dated now so
perhaps there won't be much emphasis on
it in the show but we'll get to all that
in a later video as it turns out the
filmmakers did try to start out Emma
Watson with larger front teeth but the
actress who was only 11 at the time of
filming the first film was
understandably unable to speak very well
while wearing the large fake teeth in
addition to her teeth there's also
Hermione's hair to consider which in the
books is described as brown and bushy
while Emma's hair began somewhat frizzy
in the Philosopher's Stone as the films
progressed it became less and less so
when it comes to the new television
series these are simple mistakes that I
hope will be more accurately represented
6. mispronunciation of Voldemort a
completely fabricated moniker Voldemort
was created by Rolling for the Harry
Potter series she has said that her
imagined etymology of the name is that
of French Origins with Vol meaning
flight or theft der meaning of or from
and more meaning death the mistake in
the films is apparently in the way that
the name is pronounced being that it is
an invented French word evidently the T
at the end of Voldemort should be silent
of course once the Philosopher's Stone
was shot and released with the actors
pronouncing the T before this
clarification was made there was no
going back but this could be an easy fix
for the new HBO show I'm personally fine
hard tea but I know that others are not
7. the Sorting ceremony call it what you
will an Omission or a mistake the
Sorting ceremony in the Philosopher's
Stone movie left much to be desired in
the movie students are called up at
random to be sorted into their house
rather than alphabetically as they are
in the books we also don't get to see
the whole ceremony which I personally
felt was a mistake since the television
show is likely to have much more screen
time available to pay tribute to these
more understated scenes I hope that
we'll get to see the ceremony in its
entirety 8. the rules of quidditch in
the film Oliver wood Gryffindor captain
and Harry's first year at Hogwarts tells
Harry that when the Sega catches the
golden snitch the game ends and that
team wins this is not technically
correct while the team who secures the
golden snitch is more likely to win they
do not automatically take the game in
the books the rules are more thoroughly
explained Harry learns that when a
Seeker catches the golden snitch the
game ends and they earn their team 150
points which may or may not win them the
match for example if the opposing team
were leading the game 180 to 5 then
Harry caught the snitch the match would
end and his team would lose 180 to 155
9. the mirror of erised the mirror of
ariset is seen only once in the movie A
young Harry looks upon the glass and
sees himself in the company of his
parents Lily and James Potter in the
books Harry makes multiple trips to the
mirror and sees his entire extended
family reflected back at him it's my
opinion that without these multiple
trips and and additional figures
represented in the mirror during the
movie there's a bit of a
misrepresentation of what Harry and his
deepest desires are he clearly feels so
transfixed by the idea of having an
extended family of relatives who
understand him love him and support him
the opposite of the dursleys I hope the
show takes more time to accurately
portray these scenes 10. Norbert uh
Hagrid's Dragon the final mistake that
I'll be covering in today's video from
the Philosopher's Stone is about
Hagrid's pet dragon Norbert Orton
Alberta to be exact in the book Hagrid
and the trio go to Great Lengths to
safely get Norbert off the grounds of
Hogwarts meeting Ron's older brother
Charlie Weasley Atop The Castle's
astronomy Tower Charlie then discovers
that Norbert is in fact a female dragon
leading to her name change of norberta
norberta leads with Charlie to Romania
where she can be safely cared for among
her own kind the movie cut most of this
and gave a completely different
explanation of where Norbert never
revealed as norberta had gone Hagrid
vaguely explains the way the dragon's
absence by saying that he was sent away
to Romania after other Hogwarts star
found out about him I think it would be
rather fun to correct this mistake
audiences would get to meet Charlie who
actually never appeared in the movies
and we get to see more of a dragon
win-win and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss any mistakes from the first
film that you'd like to see the show fix
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live